eigentlich unvorstellbar aber eine neue
generation von mini
teilchenbeschleunigern könnte so klein
sein dass sie tatsächlich auf einen
tisch passen derzeitige beschleuniger
haben dagegen längen von vielen
kilometern möglich gemacht werden
könnten diese durch den erfolg eines
deutschen forschungsteams den fachleuten
ist es nämlich gelungen mit ultra
starken laserpulsen besonders
energiereiche blitze im terahertz
bereich zu erzeugen krimis und science
fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
innkanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
wir alle kennen den terahertz bereich
der elektromagnetischen strahlung von
flughäfen
denn die kontrolle an den ganzkörper
scannern dort funktioniert auf diese art
und weise doch die strahlung in diesem
wellenlängenbereich kann noch viel mehr
das zeigt jetzt die studie eines
deutschen forschungsteams das mit ultra
starken laserpulsen besonders
energiereiche blitze im terahertz
bereich produziert hat dazu andreas
meyer vom hamburger center for free
electron laser science cfl um terahertz
pulse zu generieren schließen wir zwei
starke laserblitze zeitlich minimal
versetzt in einem sogenannten
nichtlinearen kristall der clou weil die
beiden laserblitze vorne eine andere
farbe als hinten haben und sie zeigt
sich leicht versetzt sind existiert eine
leichte farb- differenz die genau im
terahertz bereich liegt diese farb
differenz wird durch den kristall dann
vereinfacht gesagt in ein terror pult
umgewandelt doch ganz so easy ist das
ganze dann doch nicht denn damit die
terahertz strahlung überhaupt erzeugt
werden kann müssen die beiden
laserblitze exakt synchronisiert werden
dafür wird ein leser binz in zwei teile
aufgespalten und über einen umweg
geschickt dieser ist somit leicht
verzögert doch letztendlich überlagern
sich beide pulse wieder
doch die große hürde der farbverlauf der
pulse ist nicht konstant entlang des
pools profils wird der geringe
farbwechsel immer stärker und weist
somit ein gebogenes fahrprofil auf somit
haben die beiden versetzt fliegen
impulse keine konstante farbtiefe renz
ein großes problem für die fachleute
denn so ergibt sich nur ein kleiner
abschnitt an dem die differenz passend
für die erzeugung von terahertz
strahlung ist dazu andreas meyer
das war eine große hürde für die
erzeugung energiereicher terra hat
pulse denn den tatverlauf der pulse zu
begradigen was die naheliegende lösung
gewesen wäre es technisch nicht einfach
umsetzbar doch die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler hatten einen
geistesblitz der am ende tatsächlich zum
vollen erfolg wird in die lösung das
fahrprofil eines der beiden teil pulse
zu strecken
somit ist die farb- differenz zum
anderen teil puls passend und
weitestgehend konstant
auch wenn sich die farbverlauf stärke
somit entlang des pulses immer noch
ändert war diese umsetzung sehr
erfolgreich dazu maier die
erforderlichen änderungen an einem der
pulse sind minimal und verblüffend
einfach umzusetzen es war ausreichend
ein kurzes stück spezialglas in den
strahlengang einzusetzen auf einmal war
das thema hat signal um den faktor 13
stärker doch nicht nur diese maßnahme
führte zu dem rekord ergebnis der neuen
studie auch ein besonders großer
nichtlinearer kristall der extra für
dieses projekt angefertigt wurde trägt
seinen teil dazu bei
denn hier gilt die regel je größer der
kristall ist umso energiereicher sind
die terahertz pulse die erzeugt werden
dazu heißt es in der studie
in der kombination dieser beiden
maßnahmen haben wir ein terahertz pulse
energie von 0,6 millionen reicht das ist
rekord für diese technik und über
zehnmal stärker als alle zuvor auf
optischen weg generierten terahertz
pulse mit schaf definierter wellenlänge
unsere arbeit zeigt dass es möglich ist
ausreichend starke terahertz pulse mit
scharf definierte wellenlänge für den
betrieb kompakter teilchenbeschleuniger
zu erzeugen
ein toller erfolg denn der ausstrahlung
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass ihre
wellenlänge rund 1000 mal kürzer ist als
die von radiowellen
letztere werden aber derzeit noch in
teilchenbeschleunigern eingesetzt durch
die erzeugung der blitz im terahertz
bereich könnte also auch der bau von
1000 mal kleineren beschleuniger
komponenten möglichst werden
der large hadron collider am cern der
größte teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
wird zum super beschleuniger anklicken
anschauen und kriegs uns ein bisschen
abonnieren falls das noch nicht getan
haben solltet und vergesst nicht die
glocken zu aktivieren bis dann bleibt
dran